after all that hello reject nation I'm
Greg Alba John Humphrys me we're wearing
shirts that don't have logos were
approved to do this video we got back
from Mexico we went on a trip in case
you didn't know
courtesy of Warner Brothers in promotion
for the movie the nun we were really
excited we both never been to Mexico
before we specifically stayed in Mexico
City that's not all I could tell you is
it was one of the best times I've ever
had magical hotel yeah and the people
are really kind we walked around a lot
the main reason we went there though was
a to see the nun to go to this
historical convent and we got to explore
the catacombs there we got to vlog the
whole experience and they kind of put
together like a haunt based off of the
nun through the catacombs it was an
amazing experience something I'll never
forget we were fortunate enough to be
part of a small group that had the
director himself Horne hardy be a part
of the group just wanted to say thank
you once again to Warner Brothers for
hooking up such an awesome experience
such a great trip it's something him and
I will never forget it was our first
trip ever together in the 20-plus years
we've known each other when we got back
we got this box here and we figured
before hopping to this vlog was your
final what's in this box as it says it's
from Warner Brothers we're assuming it's
something unrelated haven't touched it
at all yet
Wow like a man it's exactly what went
wrong in Mexico when we got robbed a box
within a box second I start of that joke
I was like now I'm like cutting worse
than you do because I'm scared the price
of kaya man Wow I'm gonna keep this
right above my bed so I can pray to it
every night before I go to sleep that is
awesome that's really cool
and you can pray using this handy prayer
card right here I'll make you a deal
I'll keep this you can keep the card
fair oh great
yes err yes I don't have three of these
oh you guys can check out this fine
looking nun on September 6th beaters we
recommend it there'll be a movie review
later please enjoy the vlog that we
spent a while putting together hope you
enjoy that is still going that is still
going you can keep that side of the box
only this smells like fresh-cut wood
[Music]
I'm gonna do a crazy Mexico experience
for the dunya
[Music]
we have made it to the ExComm Bunton
convention combined so this big fog just
started kicking in out of nowhere I
don't know if you could hear the
thunderstorms going on this fog is
getting in turns but this for us is
really beautiful though
it's honestly the perfect place to die
I'm hoping I died at night I would be
really happy if I die tonight I really
want to
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you feel good feel like feel happy
for the first right now we're getting
footage over here these are the guys who
make dead meat either those killcount
videos or horror movies well now we're
gonna have to do a kill count video of
today this is the holy handicap section
guys the combat may be cooling off but
you got a look at this she's really
famous Croatian
inflated ego it's really cocky yeah this
is the reputation I want to there's a
Sanford crease by the way just the
actual dads who come to the car and that
one's for the mothers crosses are
spinning just like that one I can't
quite place that movie the crosses are
spinning
nursing so many people stand in line
just to see some process support you
know every Sunday around the world so my
mom made sure I'd say Catholic she would
constantly do this above my bed hiding
behind the wall spinning it every
morning when I woke up to know that it
evil my presence was washing over me can
I have some fun they don't survive the
buns is worth in Mexico
[Music]
he feels weirdly like they just like in
this shine part of this church thingy
whatever Jesus do he pay full price
that's what he would do
movies gonna begin soon but you gotta
admit it's pretty cool to be inside of
here right before the movie is about to
start to feel like it's gonna make for a
much more immersive experience it's
pretty gnarly actually
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay so we're not gonna review the movie
right here right now
but I gotta say watching it in whatever
room this is watching it with yeah big
dome above us an exit architecture much
more immersive experience now that I've
seen this movie I'm like I'm scared to
do the catacombs experience oh yeah
scared to walk around here right now the
thing is too late with the surround
sound here half the things that happen
on screen I thought were in the room at
first I thought it was kind of like
funny that we're gonna watch it in here
but then now that we did I'm like uh I'm
thought it was really terrified to just
walk around this place now it's
nighttime I know we walked to the same
time because the environment playing it
here has a major effect for sure yeah if
you can see it in an old convent yeah
definitely that's the way to go okay
that's a fight a convent welcome around
here right now very scary there's a
hanging nun right there that's not
linked to the movie that's that's just
part of the common
we're gonna meet them we're gonna beat
them pleasure and honor to be here in
Mexico City and a 400 year old company
with you all experience as well or are
you going to do that next
this is really special if you don't this
is not it doesn't have to be very to
become negotiating and play out with me
you know what we shot a movie with
Romania we were up in Transylvania and
we were finding these incredible castles
of history as a backdrop to the maybe
it's better to come here into this like
beautiful ancient convent is such a cool
setting and we're really pleased to be
Mexico if you felt it was scary you can
scream like this double and then I want
to hear so let's everyone can your
screen one two three
I have 40% battery I'm ready I'm so
ready
if the fear turns me on I'm sorry
subconscious reaction I'm sorry I don't
know I'm just feel that we get to extend
the maybe yeah your fault
we love attraction this just now are you
ready yeah
which what's your favorite part of the
movie because maybe behind that doors
you will find some part of the movie you
need to work as a team look carefully to
every detail and solve the puzzles if
you're ready
[Music]
my name is sister Francis and she's to
find out what's happening within these
walls I need your help
so would you please join us this quest
yeah thank you
beyond this door the early weapon is
your hope and your faith our mission
will be accomplished if we succeed in
shutting down the underworld portal
[Music]
[Applause]
something is misplaced here we're
missing here something do you see
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
haven't you scared us enough tonight I
have the key okay this looks just like
my bedroom part of film yourself at the
same time I do magic
[Music]
they're all real
thank you thank you thank you
doing it
okay we're entering active
oh really wants you bad oh yes
get that och look at that cross
[Music]
[Applause]
don't trust you at all it's like musical
chairs and there's one short
crosses are wet I got a lantern thank
you I got a lamp the construction
workers then I'm ready to go
[Laughter]
I can't wait for them to find this
leave the world on my hands the world on
a chance there's an arrow there's
something about the baby Jesus Thomas
you got this man it's a laser pointer
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now we have the power to defeat the Abel
let's do it yeah yeah I'm good
[Applause]
you're the king
[Music]
[Music]
we got you back
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
for this
[Applause]
for all that what do you think John oh
man I mean especially coming from a hot
background yeah it was awesome it really
really been a part of the movie and I
know they do things like where they set
up mazes and everything but to actually
be a part of it historical landmark in
New Mexico or a hundred year old that
really happens the reality like climbing
through catacombs bumping your head on
that was an amazing experience
that's so earlier that really was I was
very happy with it and the fact that it
was interactive that you have to
interact with the nuns and you have to
figure out puzzles and work as a team
like hardest snake room yeah smart maze
part immersive theater part escape room
it was a blast and I loved I left the
leaf on James's head that he hasn't
noticed yet
the nun rigid are